Android developer relations office hours
I'm Sparky and Munich Germany and I'm
joined by my colleagues rich and Nick
and Matt in London UK and now we're here
to talk to you about any and all issues
related to the development of Android
applications
so with that maybe rich would like to
deliver his famous disclaimer which he
does so well Android developer office
hours we'd like to inform the viewers
who are currently 0 watching this later
on YouTube that we won't be discussing
any future future future features
roadmaps or such like concise enough for
you and this is a development office
hours we're here to answer technical
questions on Android and just discuss we
can talk about things like the week's
news and Android features but nothing
that hasn't even answer it does anybody
have anything that they would like to
bring up before we start trying to drive
the discussion in any all right guys hey
LC are you by the way we have a question
waiting for you for me yeah okay what's
on your mind I'm having difficulties
with Google API console we're trying to
do to add our application to the Google
API console so we can do an OAuth and on
all Android clients and so on
and I've tried to contact some people a
few people on Google about it there is a
bug in the console and I would like to
see if you can help us it's quite urgent
yeah if you want I can do screen sharing
that's it's it's a really interesting
concern and it's it's something that we
bump into from time to time too but it's
not really in our core competency
yeah okay so if you know how can I check
where when this this issue will be
resolved or something like this or or
maybe you can guide me through
I don't know and breakthrough over
through I don't know where to throw
myself at alright whatever you want to
call it but I need to to resolve this
issue quite early it would affect not
only us it will affect everyone because
we can't use our key store on the
console and that's a big issue for us
yeah
the the if I understand correctly the
the story for oauth2 on the device is a
little bit different than it is for
example on a web app my my only direct
exposure to out who is actually doing it
on the server side like giving an app
engine app and there it more or less
works as described but even then even on
following all the tutorials and
everything is completely mind-bending I
get a headache every time I think about
it me too me too I'm I'm working on it
like a week and trying to see if we can
get an override or some sort and be able
to deliver a feature that works even
though we don't have the console already
for us and my main concern is currently
I'm using an anonymous access to the API
so Google I'm showing you a web view to
the user and well showing to the user
the web view I'm getting a simple you
know a big screen with all the details
about login and everything it's it's
it's a simple web page but the main
concern is it says third-party access an
application running on your computer is
trying to access your
and contact data and so and so on is
there any possibility to show a
different webview to the user at least
for the until the problem is resolved
that's the main concern if not then we
will hold them and wait until we can
deal with that issue
I just don't know have you now you
talked you said you're doing anonymous
access have you tried using rather
rather than when they like the full of
good try just a simple
yeah possibility for you know cuz we
can't use our key store in the API
console so we can't issue a API key
that's the problem if we were able to
issue an API key then I wouldn't show
the the web I would use the Account
Manager on ICS devices and forward
because they issued the account manager
issues and then we can show the allow
screen default equal on screen and if
not if before ICS we just allow and we
show a dialog requesting their
permission and using the you couldn't
you take an API key that's issued to
your application and just coded
statically in the app I don't know I'm
asking no the problem is that I can
issue an API that's the main issue also
about using the maybe I can use the
credentials from the web service we're
using and try to manipulate that to be
our also as an educator or if it's the
main concern here is not to break all
the guidelines and conventions while
using them and we don't want to
user or I wouldn't say just right now I
think the - okay I see okay so I had
another question regarding something
else we have a response from the Google
server maybe not from the Google server
from any server
I'm having an XML file sent to me and
I'm trying to do a stream reader an
input stream and bufferedreader and for
some reason I always get the 24 last
bytes not really from the stream
I know that it's something very very
weird and I'm trying to figure out why
and is there a specific API or a good
example or a bufferedreader to see where
we're doing it wrong or something
because I'm quite sure we have an issue
on our reader because other platforms
read it okay just wanted to make sure
something we're a very very weird is
that on a specific device or everything
on multiple devices I've checked on only
two devices on the Nexus 7 on the Galaxy
Nexus and on other devices we I think
will enter at the same issue because the
XML file I'm really in the fire the
stream into chunks of eight case and
going with a while loop on it but
something is wrong and I'm not able to
read the last 24 bytes and it's coming
from a server via HTTP yeah yeah and iOS
can read it windows can read it
it's something very very weird
maybe you've encountered something like
that or yeah I was wondering is whether
it's worth trying to use the XML pull
parser to see if you're getting all of
the XML that way okay that's that's the
code I'm using just to verify few
context is just a char buffer and be
reader is a bufferedreader from the
input stream and append the result is
doing just a string builder and doing a
pen to the string builder trying to
figure out why it's not working and you
check that content length is actually
the right value for the data that's
being returned you're not being yes no
no I checked it and the same request
from the server on iOS and Windows is
working and only on our Android devices
it's not working and this code this code
works all over Chris but this one and
it's driving me crazy we can try to find
the bug in the code I don't know if we
don't want to do that right now
yeah I'm just asking if you have any
examples for a good example or guideline
to follow to see where this is going
wrong because I want to change this code
because if it's not working I want to
rebuild it or something I don't want him
to use it and make a faulty
and response or something like that just
off the top of my head looking at it
yeah you're using ready from
bufferedreader but that basically
indicates whether the reader is ready to
be read from without blocking so yes so
it's potentially possible that you're
not you haven't got enough data left to
fill a block in the buffer and therefore
the buffers not ready to read without
blocking yeah but if I you see I'm using
also ready ready total just to count the
bytes I've read to see if I need to to
read more and while comparing it I see I
have 24 bytes left but if the buffer in
the buffered reader is larger than 24
bytes you may get false return from be
read it already because it's not ready
to return a whole chunk of data for you
man parodies supposed to start a gorilla
is supposed to return ready if he has
more bytes to read no no does it tiny
space to return ready true if it has
more bytes that can be read without
blocking so if there's an implementation
that requires the buffer to be filled
before it will return the data to you it
can return false even though there's
data semi filling the buffer
let me just post up the link to the
Javadoc yeah okay there's an empty the
under the hood implementation I think
what you're confusing it with is
available what what you might want to do
is in your else section of your if put
in something to see if you can read an
individual byte from it without
exception back okay and try that one
yeah okay I'll try it now and let you
know if it works or some
cool example of using wild Reed
returning Grayson zero does every night
okay there is a snippet okay his ring
yeah also see if you some - warm yeah
yes okay I'll try both methods and see
and let you know and also you had a
question for me sparking you can work on
who is that right sorry
you reckon Ubu yeah yeah someone posted
a question the moderator saying why
doesn't do will work I know it's working
because I'm working it also works
outside oh here we go how come it
doesn't work on HTC One X oh okay so
that that's the main issue we we also
have VoIP services has each devices
manufacturer
it has their own implementation to the
camera API some of them don't use the
exact API because we're basically
assuming the camera API from the stock
Android is working but sometimes on
different devices when we try to
initialize the camera or try to work
with the camera the device is not
implementing the correct
API as we wanted to be or as we assumed
it to be so we just block the devices
for now and that's the main issue we
want I wanted to ask I'm 30 further
sessions how can we use our check or
maybe get involved with more cameras on
devices even though they don't have for
API implementation because we want to
support more devices than every we want
to support every device there is out
there
but sometimes when we do our testing we
see that the device doesn't support
flipping the camera or rotation or maybe
supporting lower resolution then we want
to allow our users to see or maybe the
the basic API doesn't allow us to get a
hook on the camera and short on surface
you
appreciated all device manufacturers
will follow the API guidelines for that
camera and allow us to interact with the
camera without using different hooks and
different pieces of code to just support
more and more devices
sorry what I think the most pragmatic
way to approach that would be to suggest
yeah yeah we looked into it but I think
if will propose a test for the CTS suit
it will be a problem for all devices out
there because we have a very vast list
of devices not implementing the whole
MPI or implementing the API noddings in
a way we can use them so what we'll know
exactly why we need to make the CTS
better yeah but what we will do what
will you suggest to do with devices out
there just to block them and say to
users
okay devices are not ready to work and
they will not work until the end of god
I don't know one of the things you can
do within the Android Open Source
project which is where the compatibility
test suite lives there's the master
branch which is a development branch for
future versions so you can handle all
the current devices as you're currently
handling them and put your CTS tests
into the master branch so future
versions can benefit from it okay but
mainly the main issue is here that
people like I don't know HTC Samsung
they take the the main branch and then
they work on their own brands but the
thing is is held by Google they can work
on their own customizations but the CTS
is the standard I mean the guys in
London and SPARQL to tell you they're
back me up on this the CTS is a standard
which Google set in order to give
approval to get the Google Apps suite
okay they can take the core of Android
and mess around with it but they still
have to pass the CTS and so if they
don't pass our tests for the camera
there won't be certified to the that's
better that's better yeah
that's a good one the strength of the
platform is as good as the CTS makes it
yeah devices out there and you may have
to do some specific stuff for women
strange strange things but it's a
pragmatic approach the only way to
improve the situation in the future is
okay thanks a lot guys if you do that
for the camera you will be a bit of a
hero because I know you're not the only
person faced and they've kind of
problems yeah we have a lot of tests we
are doing to see a few devices of the
API we require and we do a lot of
testing to see if it works and it will
be much more it will be easier to trust
to handle devices that fully implement
the API and everybody's muting me I
don't know why yeah I know saying thank
you all I'll meet myself and allow all
people to ask more questions thank you
cool thanks a lot yeah see it was really
good of you to contribute that
discussion would anyone else like to to
step forward with a question or an issue
they want to talk about Stephen are yous
asking the best
recommendations for implementing MVC in
Android applications was that right
Steven we get an odd yep are going to
not be contact that's okay
August Android forces you into MVC in
many ways with having your activities as
the controllers and the views as your
XML files and then your data provided
through content providers anyway so if
you just follow kind of standard Android
paradigms you fall into NB C models
pretty quickly is there anything
specific around that Steven any specific
questions around MVC and Android or is
that kind of have you been ping Android
development for a long time Steven says
give me two okay
well just uh I wouldn't say view if you
really want to take that a step further
you do the do your M behind a content
provider so that you have a nice clean
interface to your to your model yeah all
right still well hold for your question
until you've got a webcam and you can
actually ask it like in the meantime
we've got loads of questions in the
moderator this week so let's take a look
over you know I'm just a little bit
amused because I just looked at a
question in Android developers earlier
today where I think somebody went sort
of wanted to go the opposite way he
wanted to have different activities be
able to read each other's data members I
said no don't do that let's see there's
a serious memory liebkind map view that
causes crash when his school map in one
direction for some time it's not yet
solved when the first bug submission was
three years ago is there any hope for
this yes there is always hope never give
up hope keep going and keep on reporting
those bugs star the issues to make sure
they float to the top keep after us and
and yeah don't when an issue is
important don't let us forget it again
other
commenting on future releases which
we're not really gonna be able to do
unfortunately so yeah keep on starting
the bugs but we're not going to say yes
this is gonna be about right
and I would just like to remind people
that at the top starred issue for a long
time was native support for Arabic and
Android and eventually we got it so keep
at it
do we have is it possible to detect
which audio and video formats are
returned by the default camera
application when you record a video via
the intent that was kind of a tricky one
I imagine there might be a way but I
just said most users will never change
it so to piss capture one once and see
what you get sorry which question was so
in jellybean it is I'm not sure about
previous versions of Android and
jellybean you can use the media codec
class to inspect the video and it can
tell you the audio and the video formats
that have come back we have some sample
code at the top of the media codec
documentation at developer.android.com
which would tell you you can use it to
inspect any video file on your device or
if all of your file yeah I'll tell you
the encoding the bit rates other things
about that video file you can also
transport them as well beyond that I'm
not sure you might have to use in
external libraries some kind of ffmpeg
or something like that might be able to
try and load and take some more metadata
about it before of jellybean yeah you
might need of it the portuguese ffmpeg
is quite a common library to video
processing inside Android
everything else is from very very quiet
like I'll speak as it said before
something is everyone else to let yep
they're on the edge of their seats
they're listening with rapt attention as
we as we work our way through the
moderator questions steven is back hey
Steven can you talk as well yeah if this
mind thing works does it's fine magic
right so your first question was kind of
I've been developing since g1 nice
you still have your g1 I do yes in a box
Jenny being running on the g1 so if I
rip my real question is about whether
mark should use MVC as a pattern for
Android whether it's applicable so we
work across a lot of platforms somebody
looking at trying to get some kind of
platform and implementation that we can
use for our products across that
bereaving phone maybe iPhone and every
city doesn't really seem to fit to me
I'm from I'm struggling to find a way
that would allow us to do what we want
to do doesn't totally break and which
place isn't it fit so well talking like
a programmer using a stone at all and we
write painting software right Google
Wallet that kind of thing so we have you
know to find flows things that we have
to do so we want to be able to provide a
librarian framework and a navigation
controlling stack that says if you go
into your pin you have to follow this
flow because that's a specified thing
and just firing in blackberry and
probably in other platforms but the way
the way that we're looking at doing it
now is seems like it would kind of
circumvent all the niceness of Andrew
you know a lot the only the activities
and the intense tax and all that jazz so
I'm thinking for a bit of advice liking
that to break it out into individual
activities so you consider building it
all in the whole up in one activity are
it will be across multiple activities so
the way the way we've got those minion
so the current things we have like the
navigation controller the modes where
you need to go next and we'll deal with
say put anything out of the back stack
so if you have to pin verify to get to a
piece of the application we go back you
don't want to go back to the pin
verification screen because that's done
so how that needs to be sort of pulled
out so that's not managed manually it
doesn't seem like we need to do that in
Android the second assessing intend flag
so I'm going to turn off from the
history so the developers looking at
this they're not they're not Hydra guys
so I mean I'm trying to find a gas
ammunition I don't have educational
material try and maybe stairs in a
better direction than what we're using
right now because it doesn't it seems
like we've going around a lot of what I
Android gives us it feels like it's
going to break things later but we've
kind of got end up with a single
controller per activity we've breaks the
use of fragments but how how come but I
really know how to explain that to
people who aren't familiar with how
androids built I it's a shame that
you've got Android developers that
aren't familiar with Android
well they're so they're not Android
developers so the the guys working on
this so we work from everything down
from C all the way up to Android sure so
the low level stuff ease is see actually
what we doing emotional core Python
stuffing but in like a base java
implementation so we have a lot of
documentation at developer.android.com
if they all at least been through the
basic documentation on activities and
activity life cycles things like that
you know the the five main parts of an
android app and how they're all put
together intense activity is broadcast
receivers that kind of thing services
you know so they were aware of their and
it seems like you could
but you you could feels like shoehorn in
MVC into it so in the activity launches
you know you could register against a
custom application object to get a
controller within handle all this logic
but that doesn't that doesn't feel right
to me trying to shoehorn them into using
saying that's my Android native I've
been around this as well like a lot of
times when you try and use in these
frameworks of dependency injection so
and you end up sacrificing now writing
an application the Android way so you
take advantage of these things like in
intentions you know do things that most
memory efficient where the only reason I
love reflections or look at classes and
so on and so forth yeah so the general
best advice a technical guess is to try
and try and write native what you can
like try and adopt the native Android of
paradigms mean if that's taking I guess
different disciplines then is you have a
different flow if your Android app that
you might have for other applications
where they'll almost inevitably end up
in a better application it might say yes
that's my opinion as far as I was hoping
that as a mother if I made more
experience or some more online
documentation of people trying to use
MVC we had a bit of a GUI around and
there's a couple of stack overflow
things which basically like well you
could probably do it like this sort of
it seems to be kind of the route we're
heading down I don't want to do I think
you know the heck now the issue on the
head that you end up not taking
advantage of all the Android yeah like
intense and so on and so forth you know
depends team rolling over this and say
yeah you're gonna end up with the worst
up in many ways yeah cause I mean is a
possible concrete question if so we've
got our controller right which is
apparently going to have a reference to
the activity if we move off that
activity to a new one
you still able to call destroy on the
one that's been paused
can you manually for this trillion hear
you call finish on it if you want to
kill it up it should finish itself if
you really need to finish on itself and
then it'll don't trigger stop on the
destroy okay you want to shortcut around
that a good way of doing it is
using a broadcast intent or are directed
intent back to the first activity so you
register a broadcast intent listener in
your activity the waits for a specific
intent to be broadcast and then we'll
finish itself once it receives that
broadcast okay I've got concerns about
us trying to manually manage uh-huh you
know the activity history when that's
already being controlled by the OS yes
it's me to me it sounds like a terrible
idea
but you can also you can also get into
memory problems with trying to keep
references to other activities it's it's
it's a road to hell yeah the minute
we've got my an activity with some UI
and a controller it's like yeah this
kind of works I mean it sounds to me
like you're maybe facing a little bit of
a pitfall in trying to attach your your
business objects and logic to activities
I mean it seems to me like maybe what
you want is you want an object with some
kind of a state flow diagram that that
controls the different the different
phases the different states that you are
that your object goes through as the
different activities manipulate it maybe
you want to attach that to a service and
then use you know have your activities
present the user interface but have them
use intense - sighs - just the service
now or a published API and and then you
know let the service control the
lifecycle of your actual sort of
abstract business object yeah that's
that's more or less what I've done so I
thought you know we look into some
unified lot of stuff so the Android
stuff I've written he's basically runs
like that so the services of the brains
and they you know mostly I'm raising up
intents to say I wanted a pin and I need
to do this and the activities shown in
this you know so yeah he does that
basically but they think I'm getting a
rolled under the wheels across platforms
yeah I think I might love it
I would think that coding up a service
would actually be like the the most
translation that you could get of your
of your C based native implementations
from other platforms anyway wouldn't it
yeah I think so so I mean so the stuff
with currently porting is based on a
blackberry implementation and so that's
really kind of what you bite it seems in
terms of just making objects and moving
things around so it's we sort of think
they're just trying to quickly pull the
business logic from that onto the the
Android UI stuff I don't think it's
really going to work quickly is one of
those business terms that never ends up
with a good technical solution
unfortunately yeah pro production you
see it's always you know the correct
solution seriously it's often quick yeah
tell me about it
well rather tell the sales guys running
point on the Facebook app that will
learn about usually wake a few people up
as the dangers are trying to do
something cross-platform
yeah it's noisy and I have most I
thought I don't know what donut I have
everyone's hangout so I can stop it
people will have other questions so
there was a massive question pasted into
the sidebar
Raphael yeah hi guys that question from
me so basically it's the simple question
I have two questions so the question is
I use location in my application and I
use different providers like GPS and
network provider depending on
availability and other stuff but I just
tested the application on different
devices and I had a problem with devices
that don't have GPS built in so
basically it's a simple question what
combination of users permission and
users feature I should use to be
available to download and visible in the
Google Play for devices without
building GPS well there's there's always
that that required equals is it required
equals false so right on the users
feature yes he's got both missions fine
location of course location which is
correct yeah and and then use his
feature if the location of network with
required equals true and then for the
occasion of GPS with required equals
false so yeah your tightest opponent
consideration is that you're applying
location though there won't be problem
with the final location permission on
these kind of devices without GPS switch
devices are you having I have one tester
with some strange Chinese tablet that
don't have GPS built-in and
unfortunately I don't have any other
devices without GPS but I want to be
able to download on yeah so you think
from the from the screen like it should
work yeah this is what I would recommend
that you used you've got the right
permissions in the right axis the right
features if you apply the apk to website
of this site and the supportive device
panel should tell you which devices
you're filtering out requirements right
yeah thank you guys and I have another
question it's a more strange and
complicated so I used a viewpager
on one of my fragment activities and
basically it have five fragments inside
on the portrait on the smartphones and
on the portrait on the tablet but when I
use it on the landscape or on the tablet
I want it to be four fragments inside
viewpager so basically the problem is
that I don't really understand how
viewpager holds the orientation change
and what fades is it saving by itself so
it looks like it's not the
or you detaching fragments when I rotate
on tablet because on create a great new
fragment adapter and populate it with
four or five fragments but you know it
looks like it's not deleting or
detaching Pregnant's on on destroy or
something like that
so do you know what the life cycle of
your pager and how I can populate
dynamically with you know with fragments
adding them maybe or deleting completely
before orientation changes so the thing
I would do to check it quickly as the
source for the support libraries
available on your computer already and
the source for the viewpager isn't
actually that big you can go and have a
look at the lifecycle methods inside it
pretty quickly it's just in your android
sdk under extras google support or
something under there this source will
be for and you can just have a quick
look through there and have a look at
the source and see the life cycles for
it i know that there's two different
fragment view pages there's a saving
state one in a non saving state one
sorry
the page so potentially the non estate
one it's going to zap everything on
rotation well there is a special adapter
or view pager for not saving you page
and there's two different adapters right
there's a you're looking at Doc's right
now yeah what the two classes that
extend let me just tell it one of the
things i was looking at was was
wondering whether you're in the
fragments you've got any reference back
to the context are you storing the
context in the oklahoma you know maybe
you should if you're storing a reference
to the context that will keep it in
memory so that all look mean it won't
get cleared out okay yeah which will
probably be your problem I thought about
it yeah so definitely I use this one and
yeah now I understand why everything not
anything working yeah thank you thank
you very much for this yeah okay
with state pager adapter so so basically
what the difference between them like I
know that you know though they are the
state adapter won't load the nearest
next adapter is a as I think yeah so
they built for two different things so
basically view pager doesn't really do
lots of do you recycling so the non
stateful one so in stateful one if
you're going through a very very long
list of pages you know you're gonna end
up with memory problems because it's not
redoing this for different different
circumstances so if let's say four tabs
which you're taking between then you can
use the stay for one if you want to be
able to like you know go through and
it's tightened and you don't want to be
saving state okay thank you guys okay if
it doesn't work okay mark even have a
look at me anyway so yeah these you gets
updated with every version of the
support I've you pretty much this and
most of all features you can have
margins between pages change the width
of pages now bezels five people view
page you've got more powerful hey so
social we'd should we take one from the
moderator yeah alrighty the next one
that I have in the moderator is from
flowers with the notification only the
icons and ticker text are public members
of the object useful fields like content
title content texts and the inbox text
fields only exist in the remote you have
created and are not easily accessible is
this for security I would say probably
not is probably more for extensibility
I'm I'm just sort of going out on a limb
here and guessing that you know in the
in the first go-around of an API there's
a tendency to to make a few things
public and then as the
see I grow as you realize that it's
going to be harder and harder to give
people access to these public members
then you start creating methods to
access them that's my guess
but I don't actually know so if anybody
knows different by all means chime in
and let us know what you think okay
so I didn't quite answer the question
with AV please try read other people's
notifications or when you create your
own notification object I didn't I would
say if is show me other people's
notifications then a security definitely
yeah I know some people try and get
around that easily accessible system
yeah okay what's the next one Sparky hmm
I have been trying to code a
camera-related out however when I try to
start preview the emulator camera seems
to always crash running the official
camera app produces some moving square
but the buttons were unresponsive is
this expected really ever expected in
the emulator is it I don't know it could
be that there's not enough memory been
allocated when the virtual device was
created I've seen that happen probably
say check cat as well I mean it's not
just going to crashing are you
definitely having a preview on screen so
yeah if you're around come in and we'll
what comes to threaten will activate so
you can come in add more detail to the
question one thing that I did once when
I was trying to test an app that use
photo intents was rather than uses the
built-in camera app I wrote myself a
teeny teeny tiny little app that
actually caught that intent and just
sanded back an image that I had stored
on my file system
which was kind of an interesting
learning exercise I hope to I hope to
put up that code as a sample code
sometime that's I thought that was sort
of an interesting alternative to you
know rather rather than using any form
of built-in camera app I just wrote my
own and all it does is return a file
would be good for testing yeah it was
also quite revealing to learn just
exactly how to pack that data into the
intent for return it was you know I I
never knew before I sort of couldn't
figure out how it was done and I it took
me a while to actually wrap my head
around exactly how that needed to be
sent back yeah I I hope to happen in the
like that the second generation of the
of the camera a sample app that goes
into Android training should we anyone
have something in the Hangout or should
we go to the on to the next moderator
question oh I'm so honest should've
added a moderator question to but the
question has to do with the animation
framework and basically I want to
implement having a fragment ops tree
click a button it would slide on screen
and adjust the size of views so I was
looking at the the animate kind of
shortcut of stringing along function and
I can I can definitely move things
around but the question is how do I get
the additional offset the zero or below
the actual container view that I have to
make it start off spring right kind of
like with the the sliding drawer does
like in the old launcher so basically
you click a button and slide in and then
another button to slide out so it kind
of like a menu or something like that it
just said it's left rotated and negative
of the width okay and so I and then I
went click the button that I would just
adjust it to the enemy animated from
that
don't make that oh you lost you Adam oh
sorry sorry yeah I'm the other that make
sense I'll give that a try oh cool okay
yeah yeah one of the issues a family if
you are using the view dot animate
object which returns your view property
animator right and it's really really
nice and this is a very clean code but I
think one of the drawbacks is you can
only animate one props it's time that
you can do animations second surfing
right may be of different types I think
you can okay thanks
and if that's not working for you then
there's a bunch of these flying many
implementations on github as well
alright well that was great that was
those two birds with one stone we got a
moderator question and a live question
hey anybody else
Andy Andy anyone else want to go to for
the price of one right let's see what
else is on the moderator what that was
that was question you guys misunderstood
my one by one widget question last week
Oh actually yeah after a bit of
searching thought of the proper name our
shortcuts and the intent is create
shortcut but can't figure out how great
one so is doing we have samples for that
probably creating an application
seems to me like every every commercial
app in the world that you download from
the Play Store wants to install a
desktop shortcut so it must be it must
be pretty well there must be a thousand
tutorials that show how it's done I've
never wanted to do it so I don't know
I've come across a stack overflow
question on it so I'll paste that up
because it's got a quite in-depth on
stack overflow is always a good resource
for these things we're all on stack
overflow Android engineers also frequent
stack overflow and answer questions
there frequently this is it trying to do
something similar to like people where
you want to create people contacts app
you can create a one belong but he wants
it to go through settings on the way
there as well okay create one which
first configures itself like the setting
shortcut maybe he did a live view and
only saw his answer with no typed
announcer
yeah it was configuration it was when
you drop it using - we need some more
but even more info base from Houdini
okay if not should we take the next one
hello my Android app to play an audio
stream works with Wi-Fi and a 3G data
card tested in US UK India on multiple
devices but in a few cases it fails with
a 3G card should I resolve this by
decreasing the quality of the audio
stream from the server question mark
what was the failure
I are you - your band ruthless who knows
yeah I mean yeah I I answered this one
in line and kind of said yeah maybe you
could try try reducing the amount of
data by you know throwing out throwing
out data before you compress it or you
can try a codec that compresses things a
little differently maybe that you know
filters more aggressively another thing
I suggested is it might not just be a
throughput problem might be a latency
problem and that may be you could also
try changing the size of the of the
chunks of data that you're sending you
know if you're getting high pings maybe
send data in bigger chunks at a time so
that the client can spend longer playing
while it waits for the new data to come
in it sounds like you basically want to
implement and adaptive bitrate streaming
so you can look at a protocol which does
that for you natively like agents or you
can try and make similar yourself by
using the connectivity manager to check
the connection type that you have and
then use that information to perhaps
stream of different quality source so
you don't do an immediate check as well
yeah if it were information ready
what a brilliant answer I am so glad to
work with people smarter than me this is
great ok
yes adaptive bitrate I like it make it
so let's see the next question says
what's the best way to implement a
calendar functionality
don't use intense or the or the content
provider to talk to the native calendar
application and don't implement your own
that's my answer
I'm guessing it'd be something like fly
or a holiday booking app where they're
looking for something between two dates
and they want to show a calendar is a
method of allowing the
pick the start and then yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah and as I've
honeycomb introduced a nice little
picker which will show you these
controls and you can flip them up and
down it's very nice to use but yeah if
you would want that available
pre-planning comb then you might be a
bit stunned
you might leave Jake Horton must have
made something as I said 15 people
probably already we have a couple new
people in the Hangout
Dave just joined us do you have anything
on your mind is there anything you want
to ask us or anything you want to talk
about anyway related I'm looking for a
good podcast for Android development
something that will touch on all
subjects like Java and all that stuff
I'm developing an app but I can't and
I'm kind of new at it I used to do some
web development with PHP and MySQL but I
can't really find a good podcast that
comes out at least once a week or once
every couple of weeks and that's
consistently updated with good
information my first suggestion is go
look for YouTube / Android developers
because that's where Android dev rel
posts all the videos of our weekly
hangouts ok good
you will also give you in haste through
the talks from Google i/o I would do
that if you run out of those go to the
2011 Google i/o talks actually you might
even start with the earlier ones like
start with the 2009-2010 because those
are the more basic Android talks and by
the time you get to 2011 2012 you don't
get too many 100 talks anymore the past
year at least five times okay and
there's also the the live section of
Google developers doc google.com which
has weekly shows and I believe ratos
making a Friday us of Friday app session
into a podcast that you can subscribe to
the feed for
is it justified a clinic or is it also
be office hours as well I know he was
turning them into a podcast I'm not sure
I'll have a quick look I think moto dev
t1 is my life change into that once
before Android Central and Phandroid and
Android meet well here's here's a quick
follow-up question so if I go back and
start looking at the i/o talks from
2009-2010 I've noticed during some of my
programming looking at text and and
stuff online that some of the stuff is
deprecated is that going to be true for
you know some of those 2009/2010 and
even 2011 talks oh it's good to get the
fundamentals anyway certainly things
like other acceleration have changed a
lot in that time and they'll be things
that you're learning that will get
superseded by information in the later
talks yeah that's true hey lists came in
average duration came in wedgies changed
quite a lot so yeah there's gonna be
things but it's good to understand the
history of time break even when we
deprecated it's a lot of times it's
pretty dental like you'll if you look in
the documentation you'll notice that
settings activity is deprecated but it's
only deprecated in favor of settings
fragment which works almost exactly the
same and you can pretty much take your
code from the activity and plug it into
fragment that just about works yeah
that's true right and and also I would
say since since you say you're pretty
new don't be shy about asking questions
in the Android developers forum or on
Stack Overflow there's and and certainly
you can get really good answers on Stack
Overflow especially if you maybe do a
quick search and make sure that you have
miss the low-hanging fruit yeah
sometimes sometimes I'll answer it
before you can even ask it mm-hmm I
guess the one thing we should also
mention as well if you're trying to
bootstrap through our development is the
Android training section on the
developer site say developer.android.com
slash training and those are you know a
bunch of
lessons where you which pull together
individual training blocks so you know
well the reference documentation is
great when you're trying to take a class
having words or methods it has but
actually like you know using a bunch of
these to build something useful but
that's where the training dogs come in
to string them all together so check
those out as well ok thanks ok and with
that we've actually hit three o'clock so
that's the end of today's hangout thank
you all for joining us and asking
questions again and coming back next
week's hangout may be slightly different
now we have a meaning what's that you'll
see you're coming to zero right yeah
we're going to be an Israel next week so
I look out for the earth as it may
change time slightly try and get
scheduled in alright see ya thanks very
much thanks for guys bye guys